our six-month investigation into sexual
assaults against more than a dozen
current and former cadets at the Air
Force Academy is prompting calls for
dramatic reform in an investigation only
on CBS this morning the cadets told us
they were retaliated against by peers
and military leadership for reporting
sexual assaults New York Democratic
senator Kirsten Gillibrand is calling
for Senate hearings and an investigation
by the Defense Department's inspector
general after watching our reports she
talked with us yesterday I think there
needs to be an IG investigation there
needs to be a thorough investigation of
why justice was not done in this case
and that's not good enough the
performance is not good enough they are
not holding perpetrators accountable
Emily Hazen was supposed to graduate in
2015 has a commissioned officer from the
elite United States Air Force Academy I
was sexually assaulted my freshman year
and the sexual harassment eventually
made me leave whatever happened to that
cadet he graduated and what happened to
you I left there's no understanding in
the commander's about sexual assault the
trauma the effects I was terrified of
reporting because I've heard of things
that happened to people and it did
happen to me so it's not horror stories
it's slut-shaming it's victim blaming
it's rumors do you regret reporting the
assault Theresa Beasley worked with
sexual assault survivors for three
decades ten of those years as the United
States Air Force Academy's top official
on sexual assault prevention and
response is the Air Force Academy's
supportive of those who report sexual
assault I would have to say absolutely
not
no I think deep down they really don't
believe that sexual assaults are
happening I think they're minimizing the
severity of them the Academy's new
superintendent Lieutenant General Jay
Silverio appeared on our broadcast to
respond do you think that there are
problems there I don't think there are
problems and let me tell you why we know
that across the nation and across
campuses this is underreported so I want
reporting to go up so that I can provide
that care provide that support
with us now is retired colonel Don
Christiansen he served as chief
prosecutor for the US Air Force from
2010 to 2014 he's now president of
protect our defenders an organization
dedicated to ending rape and sexual
assault in the military
Colonel Kristensen good morning good
morning Nora you heard the
superintendent of the air force academy
say here he does not think the Academy
has a problem yeah that was stunning air
force's own numbers show that last
academic year and these numbers came out
in March of this year eleven point two
percent of all women cadets were
sexually assaulted during that academic
year forty-seven percent were sexually
harassed yes they have a sexual assault
problem sexual harassment problem what
is it that the superintendent of the Air
Force Academy should be doing he is the
only person on that installation has the
authority to prosecute people he made it
sound like Theresa Beasley was the
reason there's a failure there Theresa
Beasley's job is to provide support just
to survivors her job is not to prosecute
her job was not to stop retaliation that
is the generals job we talked about cute
when he said that good I'm sorry I'm
just gonna say we spoke with Senator
Gillibrand yesterday who was extremely
strong on this issue not only calling
for hearings she called what the general
said pathetic she said it was
embarrassing she said not once did he
say that they received justice because
they haven't she said there's been no
accountability and the senator is
absolutely right as the general talked
about he's talked to all he talked about
was support he never once talked about
holding offenders accountable and that
is a huge failure you have to do more
you supports a great but when you have
people out there being hurt you need to
make sure that somebody is holding those
who hurt them accountable why didn't it
strike you when he said that he would
like to see the number of reporting
incidents go up did that make sense to
you it makes sense in a degree and that
you can't address sexual assault if you
don't know about it but the reality is
when women come forward and reported the
academy and snores investigation showed
they're putting the career apparel you
know the investigation showed 11 women
were forced out of the Academy last year
and so it's a career under
what does that do that what that does is
denies this country women like nor talk
to who want to serve look this is a
retention issue this a recruiting issue
this is the ability for America to bring
the fight to the enemy we have to have
women you women say an ORS report they
regret coming forward and you said that
you have some cases but the women say to
you that they have regrets about coming
forward to why well yeah absolutely we
have had five cadets coming to protect
our defenders in the last six weeks
asking for help and every one of them
saying that their career at the academy
is being put into jeopardy because they
came forward and what happens after they
come forward too often the commander's
now start looking for any minor
discrepancy to force them out of the
Academy the general suggested in this
reporting issue that it was like all
other colleges how compare the Academy
to the problem that happens at other
colleges as well well the numbers are
hard to compare because you have
thousands of colleges but the difference
the Air Force Academy it's a very
isolated institution you know the
demented women just can't leave you know
they have to have permission leave the
campus their entire life that revolves
around that campus and so if you're
being retaliated against whether it's
social retaliation professional
retaliation that impacts you every
minute of that day right and also
because if you go to an to an academy of
service academy you then oh the military
time afterwards to pay back for that
tuition absolutely and the women who are
being forced out are now being told that
they're gonna have to pay up to a
quarter million dollars back to the
government further for their education
were you angry at what you saw yesterday
very I agree with Senator Gillibrand his
response was pathetic he had an
opportunity to come in tell American
people that I've got this and I'm going
to take this seriously he had
opportunity to tell the cadets
importantly at the academy that sexual
assault and sexual harassment and
retaliation is unacceptable and he
failed to do that colonel dawn
Kristensen thank you very much for
coming in today the question DC